there were big hearings today about the  malla report and just incredible  revelations came out of the testimony  yeah this was a big one Senator Lindsey  Graham admitted he didn't read the whole  Muller report yes yes when asked why  Graham said I'm waiting for the movie  yeah looking forward to that that's all  I expected that one to get so the big  story of course was that Attorney  General William Barr testified that was  huge people think William bars testimony  today could really hurt him yes in fact  it was so bad he might even have to stay  in the Trump administration is that  rough ok worse than death everyone's  weighing in a former FBI director James  Comey wrote in an article that President  Trump eats your soul in small bites eats  your soul in small bites and responds  President Trump said that's a lie I've  never taken a small bite in my life  [Applause]